now it is time once again for our puppy
pig skin picks with subaru of las vegas
and the animal foundation amy is here
with us amy who did you bring along with
you
this is sierra and she is 10 years young
and loves playing ball and walks really
great on the leash and
his tiny little hot dogs yes sierra also
seems extremely obedient very well
behaved just
just out here uh just responds to the
command she seems like very easy to get
into a house
yeah and that's what she's really
missing right now is she doesn't
she's not doing the best in the shelter
she's just looking for a home
so she's just ready to go yeah what do
people need to know if they're
interested in sierra or any other animal
that is there right now
to go onto our website at
animalfoundation.com
then what we need you to do is go ahead
and pick a pet even if it says foster
they are available
then once you've picked the pet give us
a call and we will make an appointment
for you
excellent sierra it is time it is time
for you to make an important decision
today it is chiefs
it is bills it is the afc championship
go ahead and make your pick
let's go sierra there you go
it is the chiefs patrick mahomes you've
got sierra on your back
all right so uh if you would like to
adopt sierra you can call the number
on your screen to make an appointment
nine five five five nine zero one now
very quickly before we go to the next
story
i will point out the dogs this year are
11 and
seven so if you follow the doggy picks
this year take that sports books
oh boy made over to you